if you follow my channel you know I'm
all about that bass about that bass
about that Firebase no sequel because
honestly I'm just too lazy to build a
back end that won't get hacked to Pieces
as soon as it goes live I find it much
easier to sell my soul to Google in
exchange for a real-time app with one
line of JavaScript I'm no Apex Alpha
Giga Chad building my own back end and
rust just to serve five monthly active
users a back end as a service is an
extremely complicated product for a
company to offer you need to take a
bunch of disparate Cloud infrastructure
pieces like databases and servers then
write sdks for multiple Platforms in
multiple languages then secure and
document everything for the lowest
common developer it's not easy and for
many years the only game in town was
Firebase but that's not the case in 2023
I tried out five different Firebase
alternatives to find out which bass is
best including amplify mongodb realm
Super Bass and host and apprite will
compare popularity pricing features and
potential drawbacks of each one of these
platforms but first I want to take a
look at Firebase to give you a baseline
for comparison its web SDK gets over a
million downloads per week but is even
more popular on mobile and is used by
many popular game studios Firebase has a
ton of features like analytics
crashlytics performance monitoring and
so on but the three most critical for
app developers are user authentication
database and server-side functions these
infrastructure pieces are hosted by
Google Cloud platform and what Firebase
does is provide sdks for front-end
applications like JavaScript iOS Android
flutter Unity Etc so developers can
access them without having to architect
deploy and maintain their own
server-side code which either requires a
ton of manual labor or trillions of
dollars to hire Engineers to do it for
you when it comes to pricing Firebase
has a generous free tier then
authentication is always free with the
exception of phone and multi-factoroth
but the firestore database and Cloud
function scale up based on usage in some
cases it can be expensive at scale but
it really depends on the application and
you should carefully calculate pricing
based on your anticipated growth most of
my projects grow by a factor of zero
which makes Firebase very affordable now
one of the biggest drawbacks when using
Firebase is that you're locked in most
notably firestore is a proprietary
database which means if you ever want to
use a different database you'd have the
big undertaking of migrating that data
somewhere else Firebase is Just Like
Cocaine it feels great to get things
done quickly but trying to come off of
it is not very fun cocaine is a hell of
a drug on Firebase we can flip a switch
for Google authentication then Implement
basic oauth with a single line of code
we can then listen to the auth state in
real time then take the user ID to make
queries to the database not only is the
code incredibly simple but when data on
the server changes it magically updates
the UI basically you get real-time apps
for free and that brings us to AWS
amplify which is Amazon's answer to
Firebase it has a very impressive list
of features that include things like
analytics predictions and notifications
that aren't found on many of the other
options on this list its primary
database is dynamodb which I found to be
pretty painful to work with in the past
however amplify automatically creates a
graphql API for your data it even has a
no code tool to Define relationships for
your data and it is possible to also
connect a relational database to your
API in addition you can make your data
searchable with elasticsearch which is a
big missing feature in Firebase user
authentication is handled by AWS Cognito
which feels a bit more mature than what
Firebase offers most importantly you can
create user groups then control what
those user groups have access to in your
project like Firebase pricing as pay as
you go so you'll need to carefully
calculate usage to figure out how
quickly your money will evaporate and
you can also expect vendor lock-in here
if you use proprietary AWS products it
has sdks for all the major web and
mobile platforms and is really the only
one on this list that challenges the
popularity of Firebase with about 400
000 weekly downloads now if we jump into
some code you'll notice a much different
developer experience amplify relies
heavily on code generation to create the
back end API for your data this dumps a
bunch of code into your project that
you'll have to constantly sync with AWS
but it creates a great developer
experience for data fetching because you
have a graphql schema that provides
intellisense but at the same time you
don't need to manually write graphql
queries you get nice simple one-liners
just like the Firebase SDK and that
brings us to our next platform Superbass
it's been around since Y combinator
season 20 and has the core features you
would expect like auth file storage and
serverless functions but its main
distinguishing feature is the database
it uses the open source postgres a
relational database this provides
several advantages for one it provides a
more flexible and Industry standard way
to model data and two you don't have to
worry as much about vendor lock-in
because you can host a postgres database
anywhere one drawback though is that
there are some missing features like
website hosting which means you'll
likely also need something like versel
and netlify and its sdks are really only
focused on the web with the exception of
tools like react native flutter and
ionic they don't seem to be too focused
on the iOS Android side of things it has
gotten pretty popular on the web with
over 40 000 weekly downloads currently
when it comes to pricing there is a free
tier but you're limited to only two
projects and they'll sleep after
inactivity for a serious project pricing
starts at 25 dollars per month but it
contains enough usage to take you up to
a hundred thousand monthly active users
then turns into pay as you go after that
overall it's a great deal when you
compare it to pricing for relational
databases elsewhere the real magic of
Super Bass though is that it makes
relational databases easy to work with
it gives us a browser-based tool to
manage our data and integrates nicely
with user authentication where we can
Implement row level security policies to
control who has access to our data and I
found its JavaScript SDK very enjoyable
to work with it's a lot like the
original Firebase SDK where you use dot
notation to grab the data you want and
then perform operations on it what's
cool though is that it also supports
graphql so you have that option as an
alternative postgres also supports
things like full text search and can
return the count of a table which
annoyingly is not possible in Firebase
when it comes to real-time access to
data you'll have to opt in manually it
doesn't just work out of the box but
once you do that you can easily
subscribe to it from your front end code
with the SDK next on the list we have in
host the open source Firebase
alternative with graphql this project is
built on top of hasura a very cool
platform I've broken down in the past
that can take a relational database and
turn it into a graphql API pricing is
very similar to Superbass free to play
around with and 25 bucks a month to get
serious if we look look at npm downloads
it doesn't have a ton of traffic but
hasura is extremely popular so that
metric doesn't really paint the full
picture in this case the UI is nice and
intuitive and allows you to visualize
all your database records here in the
browser what's special about n-host
though is that your postgres database is
also a graphql API that means you can
play around with queries and mutations
right here in the browser as well it's
important to point out though that you
can't do everything from the N host
dashboard in some cases you'll need to
access hasura to do things like update
your database permissions and security
rules that might feel somewhat awkward
but they do a good job of documenting
everything now let's take a look at some
code and host has first class support
for react and provides hooks to perform
authentication with a single line of
code when it comes to database queries
things will get a little more
complicated because at that point you'll
be working with graphql and Apollo
client these are awesome Technologies
but there is a learning curve and the
code tends to be a bit more verbose than
what you would expect with Firebase for
example to fetch items from a database
we first need to go to hasura and add
the table and columns to the schema then
to find permissions to allow access to
that data and we probably also want to
go to the graphql Explorer to test out
the query before we add it to our code
we can then run it with the use Query
hook provided by Apollo client on one
hand this code feels a bit more robust
than Firebase but there's also more
friction if you're just prototyping
something quickly ultimately n host
feels like a very close competitor to
supabass but if you're into graphql
you'll likely have a preference for the
way nose does things next up we have
apprite which is another open source
backend for web and mobile developers it
has the same infrastructure pieces as n
host and Superbass but has sdks for both
the web and mobile as of today it's not
a commercial product yet which means you
need to self-host it which can be done
with a one-click install on digitalocean
but they are coming out with a fully
managed service called apprite cloud in
the near future it's free and open
source so you don't have to worry about
vendor lock-in but paradoxically free
and open source can actually be more
expensive because you don't have a cash
burning startup willing to lose money on
YouTube had its growth numbers to raise
more money in the future in terms of
popularity the JavaScript SDK doesn't
have a ton of downloads but but the
docker image has over 5 million pools go
ahead and pull it to spin up the apprite
dashboard in your browser it has an
impressive list of authentication
methods but the most interesting thing
to me is the database it's a no SQL
document database kind of like mongodb
or firestore and I found it very easy to
use but it also felt kind of mysterious
to me I did some research and found that
it's based on mariadb which is actually
a relational database and a fork of
MySQL basically what they're doing is
giving you a no SQL API to work with a
traditional SQL database this is not
unheard of and was inspired by previous
work from Wix if we jump into the code
we'll find a lot of easy one-liners for
authentication and database management
like you'd expect from a platform like
this one thing it doesn't support though
at this point is graphql in any case
apprite does feel like a tool with a lot
of potential and that brings us to the
final product on this list mongodb realm
as you may know mongodb is the most
popular document oriented database out
there and realm was a startup that was
acquired a few years ago that focused on
providing tools for mobile developers
today it can sync data from mongodb
Atlas to any web or mobile platform the
JavaScript SDK doesn't have a ton of
downloads but it's highly focused on
mobile platforms so that doesn't paint
the whole picture pricing will primarily
depend on how you use mongodb through
Atlas which can either be serverless or
dedicated then you have additional
pay-as-you-go pricing for compute time
on things like serverless functions if
we go to the dashboard we'll find
features like authentication although it
does feel a bit limited compared to
other options the real power is in the
database and the ability to sync it with
front-end applications it's also capable
of generating a graphql API from your
database when it comes to accessing data
things feel a little more complex than
Firebase because you'll also need to
think about a schema to Define realm
objects which translate mongodb data
into something you can actually use in
your application once you have it set up
it does make real-time subscriptions
very easy to manage and you can also use
graphql in Apollo if you prefer overall
I think realm is a great option but may
feel a little more advanced compared to
some of the other options we've looked
at and it's a no-brainer if you're
already using mongodb before we wrap up
there's one other platform that I want
want to mention called parse it's been
around since 2013 and was acquired by
Facebook and subsequently shut down a
few years later it's now open source and
still actively maintained today but I
just haven't tried it myself ultimately
nothing is perfect and it all comes down
to trade-offs the only thing that
matters is that you get your app shipped
just to marry the best looking one and
hope it all works out in the end but
don't ever get divorced because then
you'll be paying alimony and child
support to your legacy apps and finally
if you want to see more advanced
tutorials about these platforms
subscribe to my brand new channel Beyond
fireship thanks for watching and I will
see you in the next one